عام مر على اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا التي
غيرت وجهها اوروبا ومعها العالم اجمع الذي
عانى وما زال يعاني من تدعيه حرب يصعب
التكهن بنتائجها وكعدتها معارك بتاثير
عالمي القصه بدات قبل سنوات طويله عندما
اختارت كييف الانفصال عن اتحاد قصري جمعها
وسائل عديده الى انها قررت اللجوء للحل
الاخير وهو الحرب تحديدا بتاريخ الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير العام 2022 في الساعه
الخامسه والنصف صباحا بعد خطاب تاريخي
لرئيس فلاديمير بوتين الجيش الروسي وبدون
سابق انذار ينفذ هجوما على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من اربع جبهات جنوبا من شبه
جزيره القرم وكذلك من الشرق عبر اقليم
الدومباس ومن الشمال الشرقي في ومن الشمال
الاتجاه كياف مرورا بيتشار نوبل ايام
قليله مرت قبل بلوغ القوات الروسيه
العاصمه الجيش الروسي زحف بسرعه ولم تقف
امامه او لم تقف بوجهه الى الاوحال
والازدحام الذي صنعتهم وعدته في اتجاه
كياف اما جنوبا كانت النتائج اكثر ابهارا
سيطره على خرسون على ميلوتوبول على محطه
النوويه التي تعتبر من اكبر المحطات في
اوروبا هنا ماريو بول كانت تحت الحصار الى
ان نهايه هذا الحصار كانت قصه اخرى في ظل
الصواريخ الغربيه المضاده للدبابات والسيل
الدعم العسكري
خرجت اداره او اراده اوكرانيه من العدم
واعاقه مواصله الروس لتقدمهم في اوكرانيا
عامل اخر لا يزال لغزا الى اليوم عجز
الطيران الروسي عن فرض السياده الجويه
الكامله
النتيجه مشاه تائهون دون تغطيه من
المدفعيه والسلاح الجو مشاهد لن تنسى انهت
المرحله الاولى روسيا بعدها تعدل خطتها
وتعلن عن المرحله الثانيه بانسحابها من
محور
القوات المنسحبه لم تعد الى الديار بل
انتقلت الى
وهنا شرقا اطلقت 60 الف قذيفه مدفعيه
يوميا استراتيجيه طبعا تكللت بالسيطره على
ماريو بول
مرحله ثالثه اعلنتها اوكرانيا هذه المره
بحلول شهر سبتمبر بعد ان نفذت هجوما مضادا
من محور خرسون ودفعت القوات الروسيه
للتراجع في خساره قاسيه على موسكو هنا
القوات الروسيه ابتلعت الطعم وحشدت قواتها
الهزيله جنوبا بينما كانت اوكرانيا تعد
هجوم في الشمال ولكن نقص عدد القوات
الروسيه التي فرض عليها القتال على جبهه
طولها
1200 كيلومتر وتجنبا للخسائر انسحبت موسكو
هذه المره من كوبيانك
وكذلك لمن وكخطوه استباقيه لتدارك الموقف
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لم يقف
متفرجا واعلنت تعبئه الجزئيه لاول مره منذ
حرب الشيشان سياسيا اعلن عن استفتاءات لضم
كل من
وزابوريجيا في الميدان استهدفت الصواريخ
الروسيه ايضا محطات الطاقه الاوكرانيه
بينما في دون باس فرض الشتاء اسلوبه معارك
الطرفين استنزفت الجانبين او معارك
المواقع استنزفت الجانبين التغييرات على
الارض لم تكن كبيره معارك عنيفه دون تغيير
كبير في الخريطه لكن ربما تتغير هذه
الخريطه قريبا تحسبا للمعركه التي تحضر
لها روسيا في فصل الربيع
[موسيقى]